wait
keep
Oh
he's here
right now I had some difficulties with
recording and this is actually a major
issue for me I'm just gonna built this
little building on the side of this flat
real quick but I went there's something
serious that I do want to talk about
because during the recording of this
episode my game crashed three times and
I had to restore what I had previously
and then keep on recording so that's me
you might have picked up that there were
some differences or that I did some
things twice probably because I couldn't
exactly remember what I did and what I
lost but yeah that's due to my computer
crushing I have I don't exactly know
what this is what this issue is but I
figure that it has something to do with
my computer overheating though my lap my
laptop because I'm on my laptop and it's
really crappy to be honest but I put it
on a cooling pad even added some like
external cooling [ __ ] and I played the
game for like one minute and then it
crashed it just says roller coaster [ __ ]
three dot X stopped working and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I had a major freakout I was
so [ __ ] mad and I'm still pissed off
and I've actually recorded two episodes
in a row and totaled the game crashed
five times and I was very frustrating so
I feel like this is actually a major
issue because it's in a way stopping me
from actually playing this game try to
stream noscope the ride to also crashed
so as as a big problem now the only
thing that I can think of right now is
I'm probably going to do a total reset
either that or I'm going to remove all
of my custom scenery except for the
customs in area that I used in this park
and just try it if the game runs better
if I delete the lost custom scenery
because I've already deleted some stuff
but I still have hundreds of sir and
possibly my laptop can't take all of
that stuff but I feel like there's no
other way so it's either that or a total
computer reset and in any way I'm still
saving to get a good computer but yeah I
have only got 200 euros of my bank
account of got yeah basically I've saved
up all the other money to get a driver's
license and then put that away on like a
different bank account so now I've only
got 200 years
is left in some yeah some cash just like
but the only problem is that I don't
even have a [ __ ] job so I mean I have
a real problem here that's basically
that so if you see me not doing too many
episodes of this let's play then at
least you know why I am planning though
to get this like this new computer as
soon as I can and then keep on recording
and as soon as I have that new computer
I'm probably going to lose my share to
ronica second three and probably going
to play it 24/7 I will only play it like
18 seven but then it now it's going to
be like 24/7 so that's going to be cool
but in anyway this building is actually
kind of boring in a way I just wanted to
add a small building next to the flat
right by the way I'll just talk about
some people went time lapses some people
want me to talk well now I'm going to
talk and yeah this is just a simple
building that I went have next to the
flat right just to get that more
steampunky feel and if you've noticed
that I suddenly started adding pipes
then that's thanks to flux trans because
he was filming his bike with a shitload
of pipes or should I say a slowed or
[ __ ] on whatever loads of pipes and I I
was like maybe I could doing that in my
parks well he was like yes so I'm doing
that now
I've also I've also started egg adding
gears because I thought I didn't have
get like voting skis Mose so I went to
flux trans stream and I was like hmm I
don't think I have that site then I
downloaded it and installed it and then
it said they already had it so I was
like okay
might as well so now I'm adding gears
and cogs because I figured yeah that's
something really essential in that
steampunk theme so the rest of the
buildings especially of the inverted
coaster but I'm also going to add some
buildings to that to the free flight
coaster are going to be a lot more like
this more pipes and industrial stuff but
of course the the base is still going to
be with the castle walls from station
gym and of course the Alpine set because
this is still this is still Alpine
steampunk medieval theme with whatever
this is everything theme but so far it
hasn't it actually worked out quite
well surprisingly at least to me it
doesn't look that bad so yeah I'm glad
about that especially this flat right
though this building is looking pretty
cool so that's going all well and I'm
just figuring out what kind of roof I
should use I mean there aren't any good
corner pieces for 4h roofs I think in
shy goes alpine village so I'm just
gonna use this one and then I'll
probably add some more pipes to this
little building it's gonna be like
whatever is some sort of generator
building something random next to it
I'll probably also do some rock work
because the ground here is looking quite
boring right now and I don't know
exactly what I'm going to do in the
space between this building and the
castle that there free fly coaster runs
around where you can see the the grassy
hillside but yeah I'll probably come up
with something maybe I can just do some
rock work maybe out of water for maybe
add some pipes I don't know I I guess
I'll see as long as this game doesn't
crash of course so I'm just gonna add
some rock work and then this is not I
think this episode's gonna be finished
so see you on the next episode and
thanks for watching bye guys